-Let's go back
to earlier this year.
Do you remember that?
The Grammy --
At the Grammy Awards,
you guys took home 11 Grammys
between both of you
for "When We All Fall Asleep."
What do --
That's what I call it.
I abbreviate it now.
-[ Laughs ] It's okay.
-I say "When We" now.
When you guys recorded
"When We"...
-[ Laughs ] "When We."
-No, but what do you remember
about that night?
-It was amazing.
It was, like, one of
the best nights ever for me.
I -- Uh, yeah,
it was pretty peak, I would say.
-[ Laughs ]
-You know?
-Yeah. Yeah. I would say so.
-But it was also, like,
not because we won.
It was just because...
-We were there.
-...that we were there. Like,
you know, just being there --
Just being nominated
is so amazing and rare,
so, you know,
that was -- that was --
We were already happy.
I remember when we got there
that morning,
me and Finneas were like,
"We're good.
We don't need to win.
-Yeah. Exactly.
-We don't need --
Like, we're already here.
You know, we're not worried.
If we win or if we don't win,
it's just amazing
that we get to be here."
And, crazily...
-[ Laughs ]
-Yeah.
You wouldn't even guess it.
Crazily, you kept winning.
Yeah.
-Yep.
-I loved --
They cut to you, Billie,
right before I think it was
Album of the Year,
Record of the Year.
And they cut to you,
and you were mouthing,
"Please don't be me."
-[ Laughs ]
-I was like, "That is so you."
Like, "Please don't be me."
And I think I know
why you were doing it.
'Cause I -- Not like
we're best friends or anything,
but I feel like, knowing you,
you're going like, "I'm good.
I had a good night. I'm good.
Let's end this now."
Is that what you were thinking,
or what were you...?
-You know,
I don't know what I --
I was very overwhelmed,
but only in a way of...
it's so amazing,
I can't believe it.
Not like, "I don't want..."
You know what I mean?
-Yeah. No. Yeah.
-It's like --
how can you feel like
you deserve that kind of thing?
But I will say, though,
that the next day,
we were over here,
and Alicia Keys called me,
and she wanted
to congratulate me.
And she basically
said on the phone,
which is something that I, like,
hold so dear to me, which is --
'Cause, you know,
she won a billion Grammys
when she was really young --
her first Grammys I think.
And she called me,
and she was like,
"I just wanted to say don't be
embarrassed for being dope."
-[ Laughs ]
That is so her, by the way.
-So good.
-That is so her.
-It's true. Yeah.
-Are you guys --
You were on tour
or like three dates into it,
and then you had to cancel?
-Yep.
-Yeah.
-Bummer?
Or were you a little bit like,
"Oh, yeah, maybe
I needed a little break"?
Or I don't know.
-Kind of both.
I was really looking forward
to that tour for like months.
Um, but, you know...
[Laughs] at the time,
we were like, "Well,
we could use two weeks off."
-[ Laughs ] Yeah.
Cut to six months off.
You're like, "Okay."
-Yeah. Yeah.
So, yeah, it was great
for like the first couple weeks,
first month,
and then it was like, "Okay.
You know.
When can this be done?"
But we have made the best of it,
I would say.
I think we've really done what
we should've done in this time,
and we've made a lot of music,
and I don't think
we would have made it otherwise
if we hadn't have gotten
this time.
So as much as it's been terrible
to have, you know,
this going on in the world,
I think it has...
-We've been really lucky.
-...birthed some things.
We have been really lucky
with it, I think.
-And you're happy
with the songs you wrote?
-Yeah, we're writing a lot.
-Yeah, I love them.
-It's really fun.